Oops.
I caught the tail of my shirt on
a single needle as I walked by.
Luckily, the machine was secured and
didn't fall, but this needle needs to be
replaced.
Get comfortable with replacing needles
on your machine, and you won't panic when
something like this happens.
Now, if you have a replacement sponge
bar on hand, now might be a good time to
replace it.
Get started replacing that needle by
pulling out your sponge bar just to the
position of the bent or broken needle.
Reach the other end and grab the opposite
end of the sponge bar to pull it out.
Now notice how the needles pop up
when the sponge bar is removed.
This will allow you to take
out that broken needle.
Grab the butt of the needle
and pull it towards you.
Lifting up on the back of the needle, push
it back and up and wiggle it a little bit,
and then pull the hook
end out of the slot.
Now replace the needle
in the reverse order.
Place the hook end in the slot.
Pull it forward and drop
the back of the needle.
End of the track and push back.
Use your needle pusher to hold down the
needles and slide that sponge bar back
into place.
Voila.
You're all done.
Thank you for watching.
Please take a look at the growing
learning library at Knit it Now